it is a vacuum challenge though because
you've got to be British pretending to
be American yes in the first series well
sorry spoiler alert it's been lying on
the streamer for two years yeah yeah if
you were Keen you'd have seen it by now
right Olivia Coleman bracket's not keen
yeah but it must be quite a challenge
for you well it's also a bit of an
Escape Route because if you mess
something up and it doesn't sound right
you've always got the excuse of saying
well I'm not really that's the whole
point I'm not really an American that
was a deliberate mistake that I put in
there which I didn't
but uh so I found that actually easier
than doing doing a house for example
which I just felt like it had to be you
know it had to be right yeah because it
would get in the way if it wasn't right
were you able to get to a point where
because I just got getting my head
around being able to do so many scenes
with a different accent do you just get
to the point where you're naturally able
to perform that like never right not one
not one day because you lived there for
a long time and with everybody being
American around you did it help make it
more comfortable uh no I still I still
felt everything it was like just trying
to walk with everybody and you are the
one you're the one with the stone in
your shoe and everyone else is just
floating along and you're saying ah that
didn't sound right ah that didn't sound
right you know
[Music]